brasil vive una campaña presidencial
especialmente tensa y en esa disputa
entre ella y el bolsonaro y luís inácio
lula da silva la religión ha tomado un
papel protagonista la politización de la
fe da muchos votos en brasil y detrás de
ello está uno de los grupos más
influyentes del país los evangelistas
cristianos protestantes de carácter
ultraconservador que son fundamentales
para bolsonaro
él es un presidente que está con
nosotros que habla en el nombre de dios
que habla en el nombre de jesucristo
el presidente brasileño lo sabe y por
eso ha hecho suyas muchas de las
reclamaciones de este colectivo como la
oposición al aborto la defensa de un
estado confesional o la reivindicación
de la llamada familia tradicional
brasil es un país destinado a triunfar
y destinado a ser cristiano
un país destinado a ser libre
y la fuerza llega a cada uno de ustedes
el crecimiento del poder de este grupo
es espectacular en los últimos años
controlan desde televisiones hasta
pequeñas asociaciones vecinales y su
influencia va desde multimillonarios a
personas en la más absoluta pobreza
incluso han llegado a captar votantes
tradicionales del partido de los
trabajadores de lula da silva algo que
supone una amenaza para el ex presidente
luis ignacio lula da silva defiende un
estado laico el estado no debe
patrocinar la religión
todas las religiones deben ser
defendidas por el estado de pakistán
también tengo que decir que las iglesias
no necesitan un partido político y las
iglesias deben preocuparse de la fe
cuidada
el futuro de brasil dependerá en gran
parte de la fuerza que pueda tomar en
las urnas este colectivo al que un
tercio de los brasileños pertenecen
[Música]